what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so one of the things that I noticed
in the comment section at least one of
the questions that I've been getting an
awful lot from you guys is the question
what happened to Alfred and the origin
story of the Batman who lives we're not
really shown what happened to Alfred you
know what not really told what happened
to the character of Alfred in the Batman
who laughs origin Alfred's unincluded or
referenced in there anywhere instead who
does pick up with Batman who's basically
being taunted by the Joker and then
eventually snaps and becomes the new
Joker but it does raise the question it
does you know kind of ask this valid
question what happened to Alfred where
in the world is Alfred so here's the
deal for those of you guys who are new
to DC Comics Alfred's origin story
before the new 52 was explained in
Detective Comics 806 - 808 there's
something along those lines but
basically it spilled the beans and it
really said that Alfred was just part of
like British intelligence he was a
British agent more or less he worked for
mi5 you worked for mi7 eventually he was
kind of forced into retirement and then
took up employment with the Wayne family
and so following the death of Thomas and
Martha Wayne he ultimately became the
sort of caretaker / father figure for
Bruce Wayne with regards to how he lived
his life and so on and so forth now the
cool thing about Alfred is that on the
surface he's just like the family Butler
and he's also the guy who's aware that
Bruce Wayne is Batman and even helped
him to achieve that goal Alfred plays a
very important role in Bruce Wayne's
life but again the most important role
that he plays is that he is very much a
father figure for the character of Bruce
Wayne under the surface he's the father
figure of brutes you know he taught him
a lot of the things that he needed to
know about what it meant to be a man and
so because of that with Alfred having
vanished you know with regards to the
Batman who lost the question is where
did he go well there's a couple possible
explanations on what may have happened
here the first explanation is that Joker
killed Alfred before the events of the
Batman who last picked up but the
breaking point for Bruce Wayne was the
fact that Joker was going through and
killing all these different citizens in
Gotham and Batman was being made
helpless to stop them I feel like Batman
hears more about Alfred than he does the
entire citizenry of Gotham City if
Batman had to make a choice between the
citizens of Gotham or the life of Alfred
he would save the life of Alfred I feel
like that would be the case I feel like
he would go to almost any lengths in
order to make that happen now I don't
believe we've ever actually seen a story
unfold it sort of put him in that
situation right like you know where
Joker had like a gun to the
quote-unquote collective city of Gotham
and then a gun to Alfred and said you
have to choose
we've had stories that have been similar
to that you know with regards to like
injustice things like that but in the
main BC line of stories I don't think
we've actually had that story but again
I would say that he would probably
choose Alfred and so if Batman were
going to snap him Batman were basically
going to kill the Joker in response to
the Joker's action his incorrigibility
the fact that he cannot be fixed I feel
like Alfred would be the breaking point
more than the city the the citizens of
Gotham if Batman found out that Joker
had killed Alfred then he would have
snapped long before any of this happened
I mean I felt like it would have been a
great thing the caveat to that is that
if they done that story in the Batman
who last it would have seemed too easy
Joker Briggs into the Batcave and he
kills Alfred and Batman snaps it seems
like it'd be too easy you know I mean
having the citizens of Gotham more or
less tormented you know ritualistically
killed by the Joker more or less and
Batman being helpless to stop them it's
kind of interesting and I think it lends
it a little more credence to the
insanity of the story but again you know
it doesn't necessarily give us a
definitive answer if we look at an event
like the possibility that Alfred
Pennyworth never went to work for the
Wayne family to me that's the most
likely scenario that Alfred Pennyworth
never worked for the Wayne's that Alfred
Pennyworth continued to go on to be a
member of mi5 and mi6 agent he never
came over to the United States he just
stayed overseas and it seems like the
most logical possibility had he been
killed by the Joker you know with
regards to the events of the origin of
the Batman who last it would have been
referenced it would have been discussed
I think it would have been a little more
impactful if the the Batman who lost had
killed Alfred himself that I think would
have been a lot more intense and it
would have been pretty insane and the
sense that Alfred would have been the
one to pick it up but there's neither
hide nor hair reference in Alfred it's
not like in the Batman who lost origin
you know Batman's talking to like Jason
Todd and to Dick Grayson and you know
Batgirl Barbara Gordon and all these
characters and they say well where's
Alfred like what does Alfred have to say
about all this that's never mentioned
you never hear anything about Alfred and
it's entirely possible that that's the
case i mean alfred is coming to work for
the Wayne's was more happenstance than
anything else things just sort of ended
up that way but it's entirely possible
that he never played that role but then
again it also leads to the equation of
Batman being who he is
Batman existing in the form and function
that he does in DC Comics is a direct
reflection of the impact Alfred had on
him all the things that he taught him
all the lessons he learned so on so
forth because again alfred was basically
the the conscience of Bruce Wayne he was
the voice in his ear and said hey look
don't get too carried away may
you achieve your goal and then get out
do not get too emotionally intertwine
but Alfred's also the person that
whispers in Batman's ear sometimes you
have to be emotional you know sometimes
you have to allow motion to get the
better of you if for no other reason
then it reminds you of the fact that
you're human that you make mistakes so
you're prone to do the bad thing you're
prone to do the right thing but he is
the conscience of Bruce Wayne's mind the
way that Bruce Wayne is depicted in the
Batman who lasts in the origin story in
a lot of ways at least in the very
beginning you know before he at least
what he shows the early indications of
the Joker in that fine moment when he's
acting like his normal self he's acting
like the Batman that were used to the
bat land that we've seen and you know
however many years ever since crisis on
Infinite Earths really and the Faculty's
acting like that version of Batman
indicates that he was experienced
everything that version of Batman did
which also includes the existence of
Alfred and so again I don't have an
answer to that question you know I don't
have a definitive answer to what it is
it happened to Alfred I don't know what
happened to his character I don't know
if he just never went to go work for the
Wayne's I don't know if he was never you
know he never raised Bruce Wayne maybe
Bruce when he became Batman and Alfred
quit and they just don't talk about him
anymore I mean there's any number of
things that could have gone on there you
know Alfred could have been killed and
some catastrophes somewhere but I feel
like if Alfred existed in that story if
anywhere along the line in the origin
story of the Batman who lost or in the
life of Bruce Wayne and the Batman who
lost universe if at any point Alfred
came into existence Alfred probably
would have been referenced but it may be
that there was no interest in the
writers to reference Alfred maybe he was
actually there you know maybe he was
killed by Bruce Wayne and maybe was
killed by the Joker maybe he died when
he was hit by car we have no earthly
clue he just died had a heart attack
whatever the case may be there was so
much going on in that story that there
wasn't really a lot for a lot of room
for unnecessary mentions things that
just didn't really seem appropriate at
the time or didn't seem to be a
necessity at the time but I would argue
that if that's the logic that's being
taken here then Alfred is definitely
worth mentioning whether Alfred died
before the events that happen whether
Alfred was killed by the Batman who
laughed it makes sense that he would
have to be referenced like I said I
think it would be more impactful I think
it would have added more to the story if
on his way to taking out the Justice
League the Batman who last took out took
out Alfred as well as all the other
members of the bat family that seems
like it would have been more intense I
think it would have been cooler if it
turned out that light the Batman who
laughs was actually Alfred who lost his
mind after Batman was killed by the
Joker that I think would have been
really really cool I think that would
have been an interesting concept but you
know regardless of how it plays out
there's no definitive answer that we
have I mean as far as I'm aware you know
there's nothing indicated I guess I
could probably tweet you know to to
James 10 and say hey man like what
happened to Alfred in the Batman who
lasts I mean you know what's what's the
basis behind him 10 you may not care
enough to offer a response we just be
like I don't know whatever you want to
happen to my I have no clue I've never
met James Timmy never talked to him so I
have no idea fun fact for those of you
guys who were interested if you tweet
writers of comics on Twitter usually
they'll answer you I mean Ethan Van
Sciver talks to people all the time he
does live streams Brian Michael Bendis
I've talked to him on Twitter Jonathan
Hickman has never answered me on Twitter
but I have talked to him in person which
is kind of cool but you know I mean
there have been instances where writers
communicate with fans which is always a
welcomed kind of thing but I don't know
I mean I'm gonna open the floor to you
guys on this you know I want to see what
your also take is what do you guys think
happened to Alfred in the Batman who
last story and no just limited to my
options again I argue that he just never
went to go work for the Wayne's or he
was killed by the joke or any number of
things that happened before the Batman
who laughs but let me know what you guys
think I mean is it possible you know
Alfred became a villain that he became a
bad guy is the Joker Alfred I have no
earthly clue at this point with the way
the dark multiverse goes in the sense
that it's just a nightmare multiverse
anything's possible is it is entirely
possible that Alfred was working for mi5
and mi6 our to overcome great fear
welcome to the Green Lantern Corps I
want to see that story I want to see a
story where Alfred becomes a Green
Lantern I want to see that story so much
I want to see a story where Alfred
becomes Batman like that would be super
cool like that would be an amazing story
and that's the way exist let me know
down in the comments because then I will
cover that story anyway guys we're gonna
go ahead and bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come this
explained it make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]